mpox formerly known as monkey pox is a
rare disease caused by a very tiny germ
called the mpox virus it belongs to a
group of closely related viruses called
orthopox virus
other viruses in this group that can
infect humans include the variola virus
which causes smallpox
the cowpox virus and vaccinia
mpox is a zoonotic disease this means it
can spread from non-human animals to
people
you can catch the virus through close
skin to skin contact especially sexual
activity with a person who has mpoc
symptoms
if you have sex with someone who has M
pox it's important to know that using a
condom alone probably won't protect you
from Catching the disease
this is because the virus can also
spread through contact with rash on
non-genital parts of their body body
fluids including droplets in their
breath and surfaces or objects they have
used such as their clothes and bedding
and a pregnant woman who has M pox can
pass the virus to her unborn child
but scientists aren't sure if a person
who has M pox can spread the virus if
they don't have symptoms
once the virus enters your body it
travels through your lymph vessels to
nearby lymph nodes where it begins to
multiply
over the next one to two weeks the virus
spreads in your bloodstream throughout
your body
during this time called the incubation
period you won't have symptoms you may
be at a higher risk for catching M pox
if you have had close skin to skin
contact within the last two weeks with
someone who has or may have M pox
especially with men who have sex with
men in a geographic area where Mbox is
spreading or have a job that may expose
you to orthopox viruses such as lab
workers and health care workers others
at risk include those who have had
contact with animals such as monkeys or
rodents that could be infected
are exposed to objects or surfaces
contaminated with the virus or have not
been vaccinated against smallpox if you
were born after 1972 chances are you did
not receive the smallpox vaccine like
most viral infections M pox may start
with flu-like symptoms including feeling
exhausted chills
fever
headache muscle aches swollen lymph
nodes and a stuffy nose sore throat or
cough
these symptoms are usually followed by a
flat rash on certain areas of your body
such as the genitals anal region face
mouth hands feet and chest
then the rash can turn into raised
pimple-like sores that are filled with
fluid or pus and the rash is often very
painful
this rash generally lasts for about a
week before beginning to crust scab over
and finally falling off with the
appearance of new skin
if you think you might have symptoms of
M pox or want to find out more about it
talk to your Healthcare practitioner